Okay,
this guy is getting on my nerves so he's
probably another rabbinic or rabies
So if I'm cruel cruel with him, don't
blame me.
In Jesus name Lord Jesus be glorified.
Constrain me in silence is love.
Okay, you're excited to get humiliated
so are you ready?
Are you ready?
Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah, sure. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, sure. Yeah, the version
you're reading
Yeah.
No, I know what your question is. Are
you going to talk over me so I can hang
up on you? Are you going to listen?
The version you're reading is the
Jehovah Witness translation New World
Translation of Habakkuk 1:12. Open up
Habakkuk 1:12 and read it for me.
So I can laugh at you like I did in the
comment section. But do you know why I'm
calling?
Habakkuk 1:12, yes.
Do you want me to hang up? Yes, I know
why you're calling. Go to Habakkuk 1:12.
I'm sorry there's a little delay. All
right, there's a little delay from me.
>> Go to Habakkuk 1:12.
That's
Do Do you hear me when I'm talking or
there's a delay?
>> Yes, I'm hearing you, man. Dude, I'm
hearing you. Habakkuk 1:12.
Exactly, exactly. No, really. No, I'm
shocked. I never heard of Habakkuk. No,
okay, read it.
Open and read it.
You there or what happened?
Hey, yeah, yeah, there's a delay,
there's a delay from me.
>> Uh that's your problem, not mine. Open
Habakkuk and read it.
All right, okay.
So all right, I opened the
Wait.
All right, okay. So I opened
the NIV, all right?
>> And that's not going to support you,
NIV, by the way, but read it.
Okay. Which which one do you want me to
open?
>> No, you open it. I know what your
question is. You don't even know what
Bible you're reading to know why you
asked me your question. But go ahead.
Lord, are you not from everlasting? My
God, my holy one, you will never die.
The NIV doesn't say that, right?
The NIV says that, yeah. Okay, let's
see.
>> my God, my holy one, you will
>> that NIV, right?
Yes, the New International Version and
the updated version says you will never
die, right?
Yeah. Okay. So, what Bible do you
follow?
Just curious, what translation? So, I
can know what your version to use
against you.
I just opened this one, the NIV. I just
opened
Bible Gateway and I opened that one.
>> Yeah, so what do you use?
Just curious.
But I I use this So, you sure you stick
with the NIV?
I just want to get you on record and
recording you. You sure you're you're
going to stick with the NIV?
You sure?
>> Yeah, yeah, sure, yeah.
>> Okay, you positive? We're going to stick
with NIV, we're not going to change
translation, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, good. So, we got
the agreement, good, excellent. Now, as
I answer your question
and I as I answer your question, cuz I
want this recorded now your live stream,
Ilan, you said NIV, I will go with it, I
won't change any version, I'm going to
stick with NIV.
As I answer your question about God not
dying, and I'm going to answer that. I
just need to know what is your
background. Are you a Christian?
Uh the connection is terrible. Are you a
Christian?
Are you a Christian, Ilan?
The connection is really horrible. Then
you're horrible, that's your problem. Go
fix your connection.
It's not me. No, no, no, no, I
Now I hear you better. Okay. But to
answer your question concerning my
religious beliefs, well,
let's say I was approached about 10
years ago by
by a Jew Ah, here we go. The stupid
rabbis, yeah, yeah.
Yeah. No, I lost faith.
And
so I
>> So let me say let me let me guess. Hold
on, Yala. Let me see. You were stupid
enough You were stupid enough Listen to
me, Yala. You were stupid enough to
believe the rabbis because you thought
they're smart. So now you think
Christianity's false cuz I'm going to
use the Tanakh to bury you and the
rabbis. You ready?
Tell me you were that stupid that you
left Christianity because of the rabbis.
You left Christianity because of the
rabbis?
I didn't really leave Christianity. I'm
more from a Jewish background.
Not
>> So do you believe Jesus is the Messiah?
Do you believe Jesus is the Messiah?
That Jesus is the Messiah? Of course
not.
Of course not. So why did you say I just
got your record, you wicked demon, that
you said you didn't leave Christianity
when you just said Jesus is not the
Messiah?
Because you told me I left Christianity.
I'm originally not a Christian to leave
Christianity.
>> what is your concern What is your
concern
with Christianity? Why are you calling
me asking me about Christianity?
I have no idea why the algorithm of
YouTube got me on your channel. I popped
in on a live conversation. I heard about
So are you So now Now that you say
you're not a Christian, don't worry
about my New Testament cuz now I want
you to explain to me who your God is
from your Tanakh.
You ready?
Yeah, sure. Let's go ahead.
>> You sure?
You read Hebrew, right? So I'm going to
catch you in a lie. You read Hebrew,
right?
I'm not that not in Hebrew. Sorry.
>> Ah, very convenient. Now you don't know
Hebrew. Beautiful. Baruch Hashem. You
don't know Hebrew. Okay, go to Isaiah,
Yeshayahu, Isaiah 52:13.
I stick with the NIV instead, all right?
>> So you can do what you want, but I don't
know why why a Jew who doesn't believe
in Jesus wants to go with a Christian
translation. I prefer your your Tanakh,
but that's okay. Fine, you can stick
with it.
Isaiah 52:13.
Just the Bible Gateway is a very
convenient site, but
>> Very convenient. Oh, yes, yes. Oh, very
convenient.
Yeah, very convenient.
All right. Do you want to use Do you use
Shabbat sites? Yeah, Isaiah Isaiah
52:13.
Well, if you can't read Hebrew, you
can't help me. So go to Isaiah 52:13.
All right, 52:13. Yeah.
All right, let's go.
Yeah. Yeah.
Read for me.
See, my servant will act wisely. He will
be raised and lifted up
and uh highly exalted. Okay, do you know
what the words raised and lifted up are?
How are they used by the prophet
Yeshayahu?
Raised and lifted up?
>> what you mean.
When it says my servant will be raised
and lifted up, those words in the
Hebrew, do you know how they're used in
the prophet by the prophet or no?
No. Okay.
So you don't know how to read Hebrew at
all. So if I give you the Hebrew, you
can't read it for me?
No, not really. I'm sorry.
>> Okay, then forget it. All right. Well,
then you're going to have to take my
word for it. What do you want me to do?
Those words, my servant raised, read it
again.
He'll be what?
See, my servant will act wisely. He will
be raised and lifted up and highly
exalted.
>> Okay, now pay attention to raised and
lifted up, those two words, cuz those
two words are used elsewhere. Go to
Isaiah 57:15.
57:15 Yeah, let's see.
Okay.
Okay, read it for me, please.
This is what the high and exalted one
says.
>> Okay, slowly. He who lives forever and
his name
>> Elan, slowly. You read too fast.
>> This is what for This is what the high
and exalted one says.
>> Do you know what those words are?
The high and exalted one. Do you know
what those words are? The same words in
Isaiah 52:13.
All right. So, you see God, Hashem,
because you guys are too afraid to
mention his name, he is high and lofty,
right? Exalted?
Mhm. And then the servant will be raised
and exalted?
Yeah. So, can you explain to me how is
the servant being raised and exalted to
the position of Hashem?
Uh why does he have to be raised to the
position
>> Because that's what Isaiah 52:13 said.
Did it say the servant will be high and
lifted up? It says
he will be raised and lifted up
>> Okay. and highly exalted. Okay, in the
language of Isaiah, raised and lifted up
>> Yeah. always refers to God being
exalted, always. It's never used for
anyone else. So, I'm going to ask you
nicely again.
How can the servant be lifted up to the
status of Hashem?
I still don't understand why the use of
two words in the same The same two words
used of Hashem, right?
In Isaiah 57:15, right?
This is for Hashem, but in 52 and 23
>> those words you you're not listening,
dude. I know you think you're smart. Let
me try it again. Where are those words
used in Isaiah
for anything but Hashem's exaltation on
the throne like in Isaiah 6:1.
Read Isaiah 6:1.
Well Yeah, I know. Your rabbis didn't
teach you this because they're
embarrassed. That's why I want to
embarrass your rabbis for not teaching
you.
Isaiah 6:1.
Mr. Dog, just just just give me just
like 30 seconds just to talk.
>> If you read No, no, no. You'll get more
than 30 seconds if you don't tap dance.
You tap dance, then you and me we're
going to go to a Jewish wedding and
we're going to say "L'chaim!" and we're
GOING TO BE HOT. OOH.
No dancing.
Okay. Go to Isaiah 6:1.
So,
the the example you gave of 57 chapter
57 is talking about
talking about God. Right?
No problem. Now, Isaiah 52 is talking
about the servant who will be raised
>> Can you read Isaiah 6:1? See, you're
playing your game now. Go to Isaiah 6:1.
Read it for me.
6:1.
>> Yeah. All right.
Let's see how well you're going to do.
In the year that King Uzziah died, I saw
the Lord
high and exalted On what?
>> throne. Wait, did you see it again? The
same words high and exalted. And when
you're high and exalted, where are you?
Seated on the throne in that specific
context.
>> Okay. And now, again, I want to ask you.
Maybe it's not clear. It takes a while
to understand.
Show me the words high and exalted in
Isaiah that doesn't refer to the status
of God, your God. So, then why is the
servant being lifted up to that status?
Because those words are only used for
God being exalted on the throne, which
you did not answer. You keep tap
dancing. Oh, well, it's Yeah, that's my
point. Why is the servant exalted to the
status of God? You didn't answer that.
You You let me talk for more than 30
seconds.
>> Let's see how good you're going to do.
And then I'm going to quote the rabbi
against you. Get ready as I get the
rabbi against you. I'm going to quote
him now. Go ahead.
I have a lot I can quote to you very
much. Just let me Just let me talk for
10 seconds 30 seconds. This is what I
want to say.
>> Please, go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Let's say Baruch Hashem. Let's see
Let's see all of Isaiah. It's talking
about God being raised high and exalted.
And if if in one
uh single context,
it can refer to somebody else who is
high and exalted also. I mean, you can
You can raise anybody. High and exalted
where?
It doesn't say anywhere.
It doesn't say anywhere in 52. Okay. So,
that's your answer? So, I'm going to use
now Rabbi Moshi Cohen ibn Crispin to
show that you're stupid. Can I read him
now?
I'm not stupid, but go ahead.
>> No, no. Actually, you are. I'm sorry
because even You keep playing games
either because you know So, you know
then you're not stupid, then you're a
liar. You know that because you're
saying not stupid, right? Then you're a
liar, right?
Or I don't know. There's a third
possibility.
>> No, it's not a third party cuz when I
keep correcting you, you going back to
the same point. So, no. It's not you
don't know. Either you're stupid or
you're a liar. Which of the two?
Now you're going to another source which
I don't know. You're going to You're
going to quote
>> Oh, so you don't like your rabbis. Oh my
goodness. So, you are a joke. You're
worse than the Muslims. Okay, now let's
go back to Isaiah 6 because now I'm
going to ask you a different question.
Let's go to Isaiah 6.
Go read verses 1 to 5.
1 to 5.
>> Yeah.
I I saw the Lord high and exalted seated
on a throne.
And the train of his robe filled with
temple. Filled Filled the temple.
Above him were seraphim.
Each with six wings. With two wings,
they covered their faces. With two, they
covered their feet. And with two, they
were flying.
And they were calling to one another.
Holy, holy, holy is the Lord Almighty.
The whole earth is full of his glory.
At the sound of their voices, the door
posts and thresholds shook, and the
temple was filled with smoke.
"Woe to me!" I cried. "I am ruined! For
I am a man of unclean lips,
and I live among a people of unclean
lips, and my eyes have seen the king,
the Lord Almighty." So, you agree with
Isaiah? Your God can be seen or not at
all?
Yeah, sure. Yeah. Oh, you're okay with
it?
Yeah, but not in this world.
Okay. You sure you're not in this world?
Cuz I'm going to embarrass you now cuz I
want to show you that God appeared in
this world as a man.
God appeared in this world as a man.
Yeah, I'm going to show it to you. So,
you sure you want to say that? So,
you're okay with the prophet seeing God,
right?
I didn't really concentrate on the
verse, but let me just finish
>> it one more time. He didn't see it with
your eyes. He saw it with his eyes. My
eyes have seen. It's right there in
front of you. Read it again.
Let Just let me read it a bit. "Woe to
me!" I cried. "I am ruined! For I am a
man of unclean lips, and I live among a
people of unclean lips,
and my eyes have seen the king, the Lord
Almighty." Yeah. So, he saw him. Okay.
So, you're okay with them seeing God,
right?
Yeah, sure. Yeah. If it says it, then
Oh, good. Beautiful. Okay, now go to
Daniel 7:9-10.
Daniel 7
verses Daniel 7:9-10.
All right.
As I looked,
thrones were set in place, and the
Ancient
>> Not too fast, Ilan. Not too fast. Yeah.
I looked, how many thrones? Was it one?
Mhm. Thrones. Many thrones.
>> Okay, so more than one. Now, keep
reading.
And the Ancient of Days took his seat.
His clothing was as white as snow. The
hair of his head was white like wool.
His throne was flaming with fire and its
wheels were all ablaze. A river of fire
was flowing.
Coming out from before him. Thousands
upon thousands attended him. Then No,
10,000 and 10,000 times 10,000 stood
before him.
The court was seated and the books were
opened. Okay, you saw thrones and then
he saw the Ancient of Days, right?
Thrones, yeah. And the Ancient of Days.
>> Okay, what did the Ancient of Days look
like? What was his hair like and what
was he wearing? It's right there in the
verses.
Right. Right.
White, right?
And how many thrones did he sat on?
There's no specific number.
>> Yeah, it does say it. Read it again.
Yes, it does. Read it again. It says how
many thrones he sat on.
>> of Days Yes, read it. He does tell you
how many thrones he sat on.
Yeah,
he was sitting obviously on one throne,
his throne. Yeah, but read it so you can
see because you said didn't say it. Did
it It did say it if you pay attention.
Read it again.
Yeah. Yeah, the Ancient of Days, of
course, he was sitting on his throne, on
one throne. His throne was flaming with
fire.
>> Okay, so there means there is another
throne or more for someone else, right?
Yeah. Okay, so my question to you is,
who is this Ancient of Days that Daniel
saw?
The Ancient of Days can only be Hashem.
Hashem, good. Now, read for me 13 and
14. Daniel 7:13 and 14. Same chapter.
In my vision at night, I looked and
there before me was one like a son of
man.
Coming with the clouds of heaven.
He approached the Ancient of Days and
was led into his presence.
He was given authority, glory, and
sovereign power.
All nations and peoples of every
language worshiped him.
His dominion is an everlasting dominion
that will not pass away
and his kingdom is one that will never
be destroyed.
Yeah. Okay.
This son of man rides the clouds and he
went to the ancient of days. Where's the
ancient of days?
Well, it's not really a son of man. It
says like a son of man. Okay, like a
daughter of woman. Beside the point,
where did he go?
I just want to clarify first this
specific point.
>> I know, you don't clarify cuz I know
what the Aramaic says. It's not written
in Hebrew. Like because he's more than a
man, but to be like a son of man, that
means you appear as a man. You look
human.
I know the Aramaic better than you do.
So, where did he go?
I Can I just ask a further question on
this specific point before we go a
little bit further?
>> What is it? Yeah, go ahead.
conveniently. I don't think it's
something you go over like this A B C D
with him. Yeah, okay. Go ahead.
Uh about the issue of like a son of man.
So, I'm still, you know, it's Why didn't
you just say
uh
that it was a son of man? Why didn't you
>> Because he's more than a man. That's my
point in asking the question if you
don't tap dance. He's not a mere human
because no mere human rides the clouds
and enters heaven to sit with God in
heaven. See, if you answer, you get your
You'll get your question answered, but
if you do tap dance, opa, you're not
going to get anywhere. Where did the son
of man go?
Uh
uh All right, let's let's go with your
I'm just going to follow your reasoning.
>> Okay, where did he go?
Where did he go? Yeah. He
with the clouds. Where?
>> And he came went to the presence of this
ancient of days.
>> And where's the ancient of days?
On the throne. And where's that? Is it
in Hawaii or is it in heaven?
I don't know. I hope that heaven looks
like Hawaii, but he was in there. Yeah,
heaven. Okay, so you agree now this one
who is like a son of man went to heaven
and he sits with God on the throne in
heaven and he's worshipped by all
nations.
It doesn't say that he's sitting on a
throne in uh heaven.
Okay, hold on. Let me talk to my friend
Timmy. Uh Timmy, Daniel said he saw
thrones. One of them for Ancient of
Days. The latter says Son of Man went to
the Ancient of Days and was given a
kingdom. Last time I checked Timmy, if
you have a kingdom, you're a king. And
if you're a king, you have a throne. So
you got that Timmy? Okay. So let's come
back now.
Do you
agree that the thrones that Daniel saw,
one was for the Ancient of Days and the
other throne was for one like a son of
man? Don't play games with me cuz it
says he's given a kingdom. Last time I
checked, if you have a kingdom, you're a
king with a throne.
Yeah.
And I just please
tell you something just just to keep it
I mean Do you want me to hang up in 5
seconds?
Five. Four.
Three. Okay. Answer the question. Three.
Two. Answer the question. Five.
No, answer the question. You keep going
into diversions.
Answer the question. Do you agree that
this one like a son of man is with
Hashem in heaven ruling on a throne and
all nations worship him?
I don't agree.
And so you're saying Daniel is a liar or
you're again a liar and stupid. Which is
it? Which one's the liar, which one's
stupid? You or Daniel? Cuz it says it
right there.
Okay. Nobody's stupid. No, you are
stupid because you're saying you don't
agree. So either you're stupid, you
don't know the Old Testament, let me
teach you, or you know and you're a liar
and you're ashamed to admit what your
book says.
Did you not read the son of man is going
to be served by all nations? Yes or no?
All right, but does it say sitting on a
throne?
When you have a kingdom, where do you
sit? On a couch?
You can be the valet, you can be the
buffoon, you can be the
>> he is given a kingdom and his kingdom is
eternal, never destroyed. So a king,
what does he do? He sleeps on the sofa,
on a couch or is he on a throne?
But
Uh he's sitting on a throne, he's
sitting on
>> Okay, so the son of man is given a
kingdom that's eternal. It will never
end, that's what you read. So can you be
honest and not be a liar like your
rabbis and admit he's on a throne in
heaven?
Not a liar neither rabbis, I'm just
trying to understand this. No, you're
not because even my 5-year-old would
understand. Can you admit the reason why
Daniel saw thrones is because one of
them was for one like a son of man. Can
you just admit this?
I don't.
All right.
Okay guys, there you go.
You see?
You see why these passages are a
nightmare for rabbis? This is what I'll
do to Tovia Singer.
If the Lord Jesus permits, I get Tovia
Singer, this is what I'll do to Tovia
Singer. I will decimate him and bury him
like I would Mimi Nickab, Muhammad Hijab
and Ali Dawah.